bonjour mesdames messieurs et si daniel
thibault bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale du jour du souvenir en hommage
aux soldats canadiens disparus ces
images que vous voyez vous parviennent
en direct de la place de la
confédération à ottawa où s'élèvent au
centre le monument commémoratif de
guerre du canada une belle journée
ensoleillée un contraste avec le temps
froid et gris auquel dame nature nous a
habitués au cours des dernières années
une cérémonie tourné vers le passé en
hommage aux plus de 112 mille canadiens
qui ont donné leur vie au cours des
différentes guerres mais une cérémonie
aussi axé sur le présent avec ceux à
l'avant plan qui porte l'uniforme
aujourd'hui sont 81 mille membres actifs
réserve is here in the zdi forces
canadiennes qui sont actuellement en
service le 11e jour du 11e mois à 11
heures il y aura deux minutes de silence
un rappel de la signature de l'armistice
qui mettait fin à la première guerre
mondiale il y à 103 ans de cela
l'occasion de s'arrêter de penser à ceux
qui ont servi notre pays mais aussi à
ceux qui servent encore au sein des
missions où sont impliqués des soldats
canadiens une cérémonie teintée encore
cette année par la pandémie sauf que
contrairement à l'année dernière les
règles sanitaires ont été assouplies et
le public est de nouveau bienvenue au
centre ville d'ottawa c'est d'ailleurs
là où je retourne ma collègue laurence
martin qui sera avec nous tout le long
de cette émission bonjour lens
bonjour daniel c'est un peu un petit
retour à la normale
donnée comme l'atmosphère bonjour mais
je voudrais que ça fait du bien en fait
de revoir le public pour cette cérémonie
du souvenir il ya des centaines des
milliers de personnes autour de nous en
ce moment parce que vous savez que l'an
dernier on avait dit aux gens de rester
à la maison de regarder la cérémonie à
la télévision mais l'oeuvre on a croisé
des gens qui naît de thémines de
winnipeg de montréal beaucoup de gens
d'ottawa aussi qui tenait à être là et
qui nous ont dit on est content de
pouvoir revenir ici pour célébrer ce 11
novembre vous l'avez dit c'est une belle
journée ensoleillée il fait un peu plus
de 2,3 degrés donc ses frais mais pas
trop contrairement à ce qu'on a vu là
dans les dernières années des procédés
souvent pluvieux beaucoup plus froid on
a pu avoir aussi le défilé des vétérans
donc ça aussi ça avait été annulé l'an
dernier c'est de retour on attend le
premier ministre justin trudeau sa femme
sophie grégoire un peu avant 11 heures
la gouverneure générale aussi mérimée
semaine parce que vous savez que ce sera
sa première cérémonie du 11 novembre en
tant que gouverneure générale elle est
quand même commandant en chef des forces
armées canadiennes et ce sera aussi la
première cérémonie de souvenir pour la
nouvelle ministre de la défense en
italie sera également sur place tout
comme le ministre des anciens
combattants
et laurence et c'est le 100e
anniversaire du coquelicot océanie
oui et vous voyez le coquelicot que je
porte ici c'est une réplique du premier
coquelicot qu'on attribue au canada en
1921 en fait tout ça c'est venu d'une
femme française anne guérin qui avait
été inspiré par le poème d'un lieutenant
colonel canadien john may cry et une
flambée de violences tombe en région de
flandre monsieur mais crée donc qui
était médecin pendant la première guerre
mondiale qui avait vu un de ses amis
mourir au combat et qui avait remarqué
que donc malgré tout dans les champs où
il y avait des bombes des obus près des
cimetières il y avait des coquelicots
qui poussait et donc qu'il avait écrit
c'est dans son poème à la guérison était
inspirée elle avait décidé d'amasser des
fonds pour aider les anciens combattants
et des à la reconstruction après la
première guerre mondiale et c'est comme
ça on souhaite que son initiative a été
reprise entre autres par des ions royale
canadienne et c'est pour ça qu'on a
commencé à distribuer des coquelicots x
est devenu un symbole finalement les
jours
enfin si l'agent de reculer
oui
voici comment
à pita
avec moi également tout le long de cette
émission deux invités hélène le sait
leur capitaine à la retraite des forces
armées canadiennes et rémi landry
lieutenant-colonel à la retraite des
forces armées canadiennes et professeur
associé à l'université de sherbrooke
bonjour à vous deux bonjour je dis
bonjour se joindra également à nous dans
le courant des missions l'historien
huron wendat jean philip thivierge en
lui par leur imputant je commence avec
vous madame meuli seller à 11h ce matin
en janvier mois les deux minutes de
silence pour commémorer l'entrée en
vigueur de l'armistice qui mit fin à la
guerre la première guerre mondiale
c'est un devoir de mémoire aujourd'hui
parlez-nous de l'importance du devoir
je pense que c'est important de se
rappeler surtout les sacrifices solution
que certains on dit faire de leur vie
mais aussi de se rappeler aussi de
toutes les autres gens de cette crise en
lien avec la santé mentale en lien avec
les blessures physiques on y avait ce
que les familles aussi vive donc
aujourd'hui la commémoration se doit des
non seulement pour les personnes qui
sont tombés au combat mais aussi pour
tous ceux qui restent encore et ceux qui
servent encore parce que on oublie
parfois mais effectivement le visage des
vétérans a changé rémi landry
monsieur landry excusé oui effectivement
le visage des vétérans inchangé il faut
se rappeler que mon opus vétéran de la
première guerre mondiale
non plus de la deuxième il reste encore
quelques individus vivant de la guerre
de corée donc les vétérans sont sont un
peu plus jeunes mais il ya demain pour
moi je veux dire que ce besoin de se
souvenir là et est très présent et puis
comme je mentionnais un de vos collègues
et pas tellement longtemps c'est pas
juste une histoire aussi pour les
militaires de se rappeler mais c'est un
effort que toute la nation canadienne
fait faut pas oublier les familles qui
ont souffert de l'éloignement des pertes
des proches puis surtout lors de la
première la deuxième conflit
l'ensemble des militaires qui ont été
tuées sont enterrés à l'étranger sur le
sol européen donc il ya eu beaucoup de
souffrance
qui a été partagé par les militaires les
blessés les camarades que nous on a
perdu mais aussi de se rappeler que les
familles c'est un immense sacrifice pour
les familles qui ne serait plus aussi
l'effort de guerre les hommes étaient
plus l'eau donc les femmes dès la
première guerre mondiale ont été pris
pour éventuellement prendre la place des
hommes mais puis de démontrer qu'elle
aussi est en mesure de contribuer
pleinement à l'égal des hommes tout le
monde tout le monde a mis l'épaule à la
roue en quelque sorte on va on va
regarder justement on parle de ses
vétérans de ces gens qui sont tombés aux
différentes guerres on a préparé un
certain nombre de tableaux pour revenir
justement sur
les anciens combattants les vétérans la
population active comment son estimation
de la population d'anciens combattants
et vétérans bon évidemment il ya
ya ya ya ya je pense qu'on a de la
difficulté à voir l'aîné des chiffres
mis durant la seconde guerre mondiale il
y en a 26 1300 qui reste avec une
moyenne d'âge de 95 en garde du corps et
5900 moyenne d'âge de 88 ans et vétérans
des forces armées toute mission
confondues l'ayant reste il y a
évidemment beaucoup 500 1500 97000 en
trop entre avec une moyenne d'âge de 59
ans
comment est ce qu'on le vit ce devoir de
mémoire aujourd'hui madame le solaire
en fait je pense que vous venez de nomi
quelque chose d'important payer les
grands conflits qu'on a connue comme la
guerre de corée la deuxième guerre
mondiale mais une bombe et terrain en
fait sont associés à ces grands conflits
leur ses grognards le aujourd'hui nos
vétérans c'est des vétérans moderne qui
en fait sont des vétérans des forces
armées canadiennes parce qu'on rattache
pas nécessairement un conflit
particulier parce que le seul
d'aujourd'hui vont accomplir beaucoup
plus qu'une qu'une mission gens là vont
participer à l'effort au canada par
exemple pour les inondations pour toutes
sortes d'autres conflits de situation
donc aujourd'hui c'est important de
commémorer le service dans son corps est
vétéran aujourd'hui signifie beaucoup
plus que seulement par exemple le
confiant à bien différents le pauvre il
ya eu ailleurs donc est important de se
rappeler qu'aujourd'hui nous et aux
vétérans est trop beaucoup d'expérience
derrière leur carrière
je vous retrouve un peu plus tard
j'aimerais qu'on à faire un saut du côté
notre autre invité merci à vous dois
vous retrouve tout de suite d'un corner
mission va également retrouver jean
philip thivierge et les membres de la
communauté huronne wendat de wendake et
historien de formation s'intéresse
évidemment particulièrement à la
participation des
grands conflits mondiaux
dites-nous pour les premières nations ça
représente quoi aujourd'hui ce 11
novembre monsieur thivierge
quincy ce beau mais à écouter des rares
merci de l'invitation écoutez c'est
julia leigh dans le commentaire qui est
basé essentiellement sur une vision
personnelle parce que
la cible à le symbolisme la
signification de ces confient leur
séjour sur n'importe premières nations
et émile à la fin donc je parlerais pas
vouloir nation mai jour du souvenir tels
que les invités l'ont dit précédemment
impose un devoir de mémoire est de match
de juan mémoires de sarah contre et
l'oubli
et c'est oublier nous permettent de
surtout par rapport aux premières
nations nous permet d'aller dans une
direction spécifique c'est-à-dire
précisément de contrer l'idée de l'ain
mythe qui a invité trop longtemps le
jour du souvenir qui
les anciens combattants nation
c'est-à-dire l'ami du guerrier oublier
qu'on a oublié dès la fin des guerres
la contribution autochtone et ensuite
lorsque la lorsque ses revenus au goût
du jour on y est allé d'une volonté de
glorification des actions à travers un
prisme très particulier mais je trouve
ça important aujourd'hui revoir journée
comme un
moment monolithique mais une opportunité
de
rappeler mais aussi de changez le cadre
de référence ou des premières nations en
tant que minorité on parle le peut il me
semble de la contribution du peuple
autochtone aux grands conflits auxquels
a participé le canada d'un côté que la
réconciliation ce que ce serait
important de ramener ça à l'avant-plan
d'après vous
je pense que c'est essentiel
après après la deuxième guerre mondiale
évidemment après la première guerre
mondiale
on peut en parler tant tour deux sets de
7 10 et au niveau de l'état canadien de
se souvenir ce qui a conduit aujourd'hui
on est actuellement
2ème bien en diable un silence perdure
et autant chez pour les anciens
combattants tonnes que chez les
combattants non autochtone et ça a duré
longtemps le silence c'est juste pour
durer plus longtemps pour les pour les
autochtones est aujourd'hui moins de 2 m
et en relais très personnelle je vous
dirais que c'est un outil le jour du
souvenir d'un outil de reconnaissance
essentielle qui peut contribuer à la
réconciliation parce que le cheminement
de nos confères autochtone pensée deux
conflits là c'est un chemin de croix est
très très ardue et la reconnaissance x
l'acceptation aussi des trois acteurs
dont les taux canadiens des torts qui
ont été causés à nous faire ça pendant
les deux guerres mondiales en trop et ça
peut être un catalyseur extraordinaire
pour aider à la réconciliation
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler un peu
plus tard vous et moi j'en fais des
petits vierge mears infiniment en
attendant quelques minutes l'arrivée des
représentants du gouvernement celle de
la gouverneure générale mairie saimone
celle aussi de la mer nationales de la
croix d'argent c'est une mère qui
représentent toutes celles qui ont perdu
un fils une fille ou services du canada
il s'agit cette année de madame josée
simard sa fille karine est décédé en
avril 2009 lorsque son véhicule blindé a
été touché par une bombe en bordure de
route près de kandahar en afghanistan
elle en était à sa deuxième semaine de
sa toute première affectation c'est
vraiment si marc ira déposer tout à
l'heure une couronne sur le monument au
nom de toutes les mères qui ont perdu un
enfant sur isolation un grand honneur
qui porte avec lui bien des souvenirs
douloureux catherine poisson la présente
c'est une cicatrice qui se ferme jamais
douze ans après la mort de sa fille
josée simard ne s'est toujours pas
remise de la perte de sa petite karine
moi et à ma grande amie c'était ma
grande chose on était vraiment vraiment
très proches
[Musique]
comme sa mère karine blais ressentais un
grand besoin d'aider les autres un
contact humain est leur juste part et de
la marine et à 17 ans elle devient
membre du 12e régiment des blindés est
basé à valcartier mais elle s'entend
avec sa mère sur une chose elle n'ira
pas en afghanistan et qui a vu nos
déboires ne veut pas y aller
amodio moment je me suis entraîné puis
je veux accompagner mes compagnons mais
les frères dans lesquels je me dois d'y
aller et puis c'était son défi elle
voulait voyager
à kandahar karine blais appelle sa mère
pour lui parler de son expérience de
l'aide qu'elle peut apporter aux femmes
et aux filles afghanes vous jetterez
dans le communautaire d'aider les gens
c'était très important mais
fait ça on pense pas que notre fils va
venir un soldat un jour mais j'ai
respecté cette décision puis
avec un grand a
le 13 avril 2009 karine blais conduit un
véhicule de reconnaissance au nord de
kandahar elle roule sur une bombe
artisanale et meurt sur le coup à l'âge
de 21 ans moins de deux semaines après
son arrivée elle devient la première et
seule québécoise à mourir au combat en
afghanistan
[Musique]
quelques années plus tard josée simard
suit les traces de sa fille jusqu'en
afghanistan je voulais respirer la même
marque à la vrs pu
vivre sans karine est encore difficile
surtout à son anniversaire lors de fêtes
familiales et chaque jour du souvenir
[Musique]
mais cette année sera différente au lieu
de se recueillir devant la statue de sa
fille aux méchants josée simard sera à
ottawa en tant que maire nationales de
la croix d'argent c'est un grand honneur
de pouvoir représenter toutes les mères
à la croix d'argent il faut vraiment
passer par là pour comprendre
c'est pour ça que je veux dire courage à
toutes les mamans qui porte la croix
d'argent est l'une des personnes qui ont
perdu un enfant soit mais malaga ou pas
la guerre
c'est triste josée simard admet qu'elle
aurait préféré ne jamais recevoir cet
honneur et garder sa fille près d'elle
mais aujourd'hui ne sont veut plus
d'avoir laissé partir karine on peut
jamais revenir en arrière
puis probablement que si je leur ai
vraiment empêcher
ça va peut-être passer d'autres choses
auraient peut être reproché de paoua
fait son break
c'est le pardon que je me suis donné ce
11 novembre la mer nationales de la
croix d'argent évitera tout les parents
endeuillés à rester fort et à se
pardonner
[Musique]
les images en direct du monument
commémoratif de guerre du canada en
plein centre ville de la capitale
nationale en attente de l'arrivée des
premiers dignitaires
ça devrait se faire dans les prochaines
minutes y'a des gens aujourd'hui autour
de la place de la confédération
contrairement à l'année dernière où on
avait demandé au public de rester à la
maison en raison de la pandémie
évidemment rémi landry à quel point
est-ce que ça fait une différence
d'avoir du public qui n'ont pu mourir je
pense que monsieur landry ne nous entend
pas madame le tout de même le seul à
rejouer à quel point ça fait une
différence avoir dû d'avoir du public
une cérémonie comme si
je pense que ça rappelle l'importance de
vivre cette commémoration le en tant qu'
en tant que nation donc en tant que
population
il serait faux de penser que cette
cérémonie la partie seulement aux
vétérans ou militaires en service donc
important de pouvoir intégrer ensuite
les gens qui veulent être présents pour
commémorer aussi les disparus et les
personnes hostiles qui ont subi toutes
les blessures qui ont participé à
différentes missions il ya aussi il ya
aussi une importance et envoyait dans
les images tout à l'heure il y avait
plusieurs générations gens qui sont là
on a l'impression qu'il ya un effort qui
est fait d'un la part de certaines
familles de transmettre ce devoir de
mémoire la génération suivante qui est
peut-être pas la même conscience de
l'importance que ça ce qu'on le sent ça
vous le voyez
je pense que c'est important de le
nommer
intégré en fait la jeune génération
justement dans le nouveau plan
stratégique de commémoration dans ces
combattants canada l'idée est d'intégrer
même dans les curriculum scolaire
l'histoire militaire je pense que c'est
une bonne chose parce qu'il faut
comprendre d'où on vient aussi en tant
que nation avec les conflits auxquels on
a participé de comprendre aussi le la
raison d'un des forces armées
canadiennes donc pour moi c'est un beau
geste de vouloir intégrer les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui
attendant l'arrivée de la gouverneure
générale met en scène on est on me dit
qu'on est en mesure de revoir les
statistiques les chiffres que combler
vous présenter tout à l'heure justement
sur les anciens combattants la
population devait terreur l'instigation
sont quand même intéressante parce que
ça montre à quel point il
ya eu il ya eu plusieurs canadiens qui
ont participé première guerre mondiale
estimation de la population
durant la première guerre mondiale des
dix canadiens q-tip
voilà alors première guerre mondiale
26000 3 300 seconde guerre mondiale
évidemment d'éviter randa première
guerre mondiale il n'en reste plus
seconde guerre mondiale 26 1300 moyenne
d'âge 95 ans 5900 de la guerre de corée
ont une moyenne d'âge de 88 ans vétérans
des forces canadiennes toute mission
confondues 597 1200 avec une moyenne
d'âge de 88 ans si on regarde le parmi
les grands conflits la participation
canadienne durant la première guerre
mondiale la voyait il ya soixante
6655 canadiens qui ont tué 173 milles
qui ont été blessées 650 milles qui ont
participé on parlait des des autochtones
qui sont joints ou oran 4000 d'entre eux
durant la première guerre mondiale
compte tenu de leurs populations à
l'époque c'était énorme
population canadienne de 7 millions 800
mille personnes durant la seconde guerre
mois ali ya presque quarante cinq mille
canadiens qui ont laissé leur vie 55000
qui ont été blessés 1 millions un peu
plus d'un million de canadiens qui ont
trait qui ont traversé l'atlantique pour
participer au conflit 4000 autochtone là
encore pour une population canadienne de
presque 12 millions et puis durant la
guerre de durant la guerre de corée à
542 à canadiens qui ont laissé leur vie
durant ce conflit 1200 blessés
1791 ont participé aux combats à
l'époque le canada comptait 14 millions
d'habitants et puis mission de maintien
de la paix le auxquels le canada a
participé plus de 300 dont
158 en afghanistan qui sont tombées
entre 2002 et 2011
c'est d'ailleurs la mission c'est c'est
la mission de laquelle on se souvient et
davantage monsieur landry je crois que
vous êtes de retour avec nous vous avez
perdu pendant quelques minutes je
demande à tout à l'heure on voyait et
laurence nous en parlait il ya beaucoup
de gens là qui se sont qui sont
présentés autour du monument
commémoratif de guerre du canada à quel
point est ce que ça fait une différence
pour vous pour lui pour les membres des
forces armées ou pour les vétérans qui
sont là à quel point sa finition les
différences et comme je vous disais tout
à l'heure c'est un effort de nation
c'est pas juste une question de
militaires à militaires on est au
service de notre pays et puis on va tous
faire
notre possible pour être en mesure
d'accomplir la mission mais comme je
mentionnais c'est un effort de pays on
n'est pas une organisation sous contrôle
veut dire on est canadien on est citoyen
canadien et puis c'est la nation qui
décèdent des endroits où on doit aller
puis du type de combat qu'on va devoir
faire donc il faut que les gens
réalisent que les militaires en uniforme
c'est parce que c'est le canada qui veut
qu'il y ait des militaires en uniforme
et puis quand je dis sous un jeu les
militaires vont on est au service du
pays donc on a besoin 200 militaires on
voit être 200 milles et s'il faut faire
d'autres guerres on va le faire dans le
but de protéger je veux dire la
démocratie nos valeurs et puis c'est
pour ça qu'il faut absolument que ça
devienne un jour du souvenir national
c'est pas juste une question de deux
soldats c'est une question de nation et
puis le plus convoité en mesure et
éventuellement de convier ce message le
plus les gens vont réaliser que oui
c'est un effort et puis nous les
militaires les anciens militaires on
était le fer de lance de cet effort là
c'est ça qui faisait on était le fer de
lance willy blessures chez des anciens
combattants chez les vétérans qui sont
blessés ils sont toujours mais comment
je mentionnais les blessures elles sont
présentes de toute la nation et
puisqu'il faut se rappeler aussi que
vous êtes souvent à mes proches on meurt
deux fois la première fois c'est un
décès physique et puis là la deuxième
fois c'est lorsqu'on on oublie et puis
c'est ça qu'il faut pas oublier il faut
garder ces gens là vivent faut garder
les 13 mai entre autres soldats qu'on
n'a jamais retrouvé
dans la première du premier conflit
mondial faut que ces souvenirs ne soit
guère des vivants et puis la seule façon
de pouvoir les garder vivant c'est
s'assurer que les jeunes contribuent à
ce jour du souvenir là et puis comme on
le mentionnait le fait éventuelle de
d'avoir des cours pour familiariser nos
jeunes je pense qu'il faut le faire
parce que ça fait partie d'être canadien
ça fait parti d'être canadien de dettes
au courant tout seul et puis le 11
novembre ces quelques heures comprend
pour se rappeler et puis pour se dire
que ces gars là c'est qu'on philo nous
on unis c'était la volonté du pays et
puis il faut éventuellement que les gens
s'en souviennent et puis qu'on soit
fiers de nos soldats qu'on soit fier de
l'effort qu'ils ont donnée même le
salaire vous avez un point de vue très
particulier où là dessus parce que vous
l'avez vécu de l'extérieur et puis
ensuite de l'intérieur vous avez servi
plusieurs années vous avez vu un peu
l'évolution de la perception de ce que
ça veut dire jones ou
de se rappeler qu'à l'époque demain le
jour de souvenir en fait les vétérans à
des grands hangars donc on disait les
vétérans 10 de la deuxième guerre
mondiale vétéran de la guerre de corée
mais aujourd'hui si ce n'est plus la
même chose qu'on peut dire donc
important de salles de saluer le fait
qu'être vétérans des forces armées
canadiennes veut dire beaucoup plus que
vétéran des forces armées canadiennes
aujourd'hui on pense à russell de avoir
un membre durant en fait que participer
à deux trois missions l'afghanistan qui
est en bosnie est partie comme disons
aux inondations quitte à les fournir un
effort pour les volontaires en haïti
donc il ya beaucoup je dirais de 2
d'histoire en fait derrière une carrière
d'un militant dont il est important
d'aller médecins de l'avant aujourd'hui
nos vétérans moderne aussi aujourd'hui
on a de la misère parfois incompris
c'est quoi la différence entre un ancien
combattant et objets terrain on a ces
deux termes le en français
malheureusement prendre à régler mais en
france et que je pense au débat aussi
quelle confusion des as est ce que des
gens qui se sont - les terrains ou à
cause que justement ils n'ont pas partie
et directement conflit mais au final ce
qu'on veut savoir c'est plutôt c'est un
vétéran défenseur micah nadine je
pensais pas de moins bons vétérans parce
que personne ne connaissait grande
partie d'un conflit armé donc
d'importance aussi de s'en rappeler
c'est il ya sks que justement cette
perception elle s'est un peu perdu rémi
landry on a souvent les c'est vrai qu'on
a la notion de vétérans d'anciens
combattants on a souvent l'impression
qu'on se retrouve autour du monument
commémoratif de guerre du canada pour
pour pour se remémorer ce qui s'est
passé durant la première la deuxième
guerre mondiale il ya beaucoup de gens
rentrent avec ton qui ont participé à
autre à d'autres missions
condé plus récemment est ce qu'on pense
à ces gens laissent presse qui sont un
peu tombé dans l'oubli ne paie vous sont
peut être pas tomber d'un tombé dans
l'oubli mais encore une fois faut se
rappeler que le le 11 novembre c'est
avant tout pour célébrer dans un premier
temps historiquement pour se libérer la
la première guerre mondiale il s'agit de
regarder les pertes de vies humaines
durant la première guerre mondiale et
puis l'idée était de éventuellement on
va se rappeler du 11 novembre de façon
ce qui a déplu d'hyères et puis
malheureusement je faisais un peu plus
de 200 ans après la fin de cette
première guerre là bas malheureusement
c'est encore présente pour le besoin de
soldats pour éventuellement protéger nos
valeurs celles qu'on appelait la
dernière on voulait appeler la dernière
des dernières clamant sa part été le cas
ce que vous voyez présentement c'est
l'arrivée de justin trudeau premier
ministre du canada accompagné de son
épouse figurent trudeau qui sont reçus
par le président de la légion canadienne
c'est le premier du groupe de
dignitaires qui sera l'un aujourd'hui
monsieur trudeau
qui n'en est pas à sa première cérémonie
évidemment au monument commémoratif de
guerre du canada
c'est important de voir les visages les
visages de du premier ministre dans des
moments comme ça est ce que les vétérans
comme
je me retrouvais avoue le nouveau
monsieur landry la présence de monsieur
trudeau à une cérémonie comme celle d'
c'est plus qu'important je veux dire
c'est primordial les gens semblent
oublier que les conflits à l'intérieur
duquel les militaires canadiens ont
participé
on n'a pas participé à ces cons philo
parce qu'on est donc on a décidé comme
seul d'y aller c'est un acte du
gouvernement c'est le gouvernement on
est au service du pays donc c'est tout à
fait normal que le premier ministre du
pays soient en mesure de souligner les
formes de ses membres de ces citoyens
qui ont contribué à ces confie laure et
puis comme on le mentionnait tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui l'aide le service
des militaires revêt je veux dire une
dimension qui est beaucoup plus grande
on a vu des soldats je mesure dans les
chu celle des on a vu des soldats durant
les inondations on voit des soldats et
des aussi lorsqu'il est tremblement
terre lorsque des catastrophes
au niveau du monde on le voit aussi
toujours encore au niveau du maintien de
la paix dans des missions pour aider
donc il faut se rappeler c'est que les
forces armées sont au service du
gouvernement canadien et indirectement
de la population canadienne donc le 11
novembre doit être une journée où nos
chefs sont présents et puis souligne cet
apport c'est une fois dans l'année qu'on
le fait donc je crois que c'est tout à
fait approprié et puis la cérémonie
n'aurait paul du tout
la même prestance si nos élus n'étaient
pas présents la prochaine personne qui
arrivera devrait être la mère nationales
de la croix d'argent dont on parlait
tout à l'heure madame josée simard qui
ira déposer une gerbe au nom de toutes
les mères qui ont perdu un fils ou une
fille d'un cadre d'un conflit hélène
leseigneur c'est une tradition la mer
nationales de la croix d'argent des pays
du commonwealth le canada il se tiendra
ce genre de
ce jeu ce genre de
distinctions honorifiques pourquoi c'est
important d'après lui mais
je pense que c'est important de se
rappeler qui a justement des familles
derrière chaque soldat que ce soit des
conjoints conjoint il ya aussi des
parents et malheureusement on oublie
souvent parce que le militaire et
adultes j'ai quand même des parents
derrière
chaque maire je pense qu'ils faire un
enfant
c'était une tristesse qui est énorme je
ne changerais pour rien du côté du père
mais je pense que pour une mère père de
son enfant c'est quelque chose qui est
très dramatique donc de donner cet
espace le parcours justement et aider
les autres femmes qui ont vécu les
maires qui ont vécu des situations
similaires je pense que c'est très
influent important d'offrir une tribune
à ces femmes là pour pouvoir partager
ensemble leur tristesse
donc je pense que c'est un très beau
geste de nori en fuite qui a des parents
derrière chaque semaine alors on la voit
ici madame simard josée simard qui vient
d'arriver à la place de la confédération
accueilli par le président de la légion
canadienne là est en discussion avec
justin trudeau son épouse sophie
grégoire trudeau on disait c'est
spécifique au canada cette distinction
la sa fille carine simard est décédé
rappelons-le en avril 2009 lorsque le
véhicule blindé à bord duquel elle se
trouvait a été touché par une bombe en
bordure de route près de kandahar en
afghanistan
elle en était à sa deuxième semaine de
sa toute première affectation d'une
intervention dirigez vous le voyez
devant le monument commémoratif de
guerre
la gouverneure générale
devrait être
devrait être la prochaine personne à se
présenter
gouverneur général qui mériteraient mais
nous
inuit monsieur monsieur landry
à quel point est-ce que c'est à quel
point ça c'est envoyé la force du
symbole de de madame simone cette
nomination il était devenu vous faut
réaliser que le gouverneur général et le
commandant en chef
des forces armées canadiennes donc elles
représentent les trois éléments et puis
en plus le fait d'avoir une autochtone
il nous excuser
ça envoie le message
que ces gens l'offre enfants sont
canadiens 100% et puis comme
d'historiens nous le rappelait tout à
l'heure je veux dire ils ont contribué
grandement la première depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale entre août même
si souvent je veux dire ça le prix est
un peu plus de temps que les vétérans
pour que ces vétérans là aussi plus
obtenir
les mêmes droits donc c c'est aussi le
message que il ya un apprentissage une
réconciliation qui doit se faire avec
notre passé pour s'assurer qu'on qu'on
permet à ces gens-là de
finalement d'avoir les mêmes droits que
les autres voilà madame me simone qui
arrive le cortège partage de véhicules
de la gouverneure générale mairie
semaine
va recevoir le salut vis royal d'abord
madame simone est accompagnée de son
époux monsieur west fraser
la gouverneure générale et la
commandante en chef des forces
canadiennes ont le mentionner tout à
l'heure elle est vêtue aujourd'hui de
l'uniforme de l'aviation royale
canadienne à titre de commandant des
forces canadiennes évidemment elles
portent l'uniforme
elle se présente accueilli par le
président legrand président de la légion
elle ira ensuite rencontrer les autres
dignitaires qui sont arrivés un peu un
peu avant elle le président puis ensuite
évidemment le salut celui vie sur royal
qui sera qui sera
prodigués sur place elle a une seule
heure j'ai envie de vous demander à
travers tout cela ils n'ont pas beaucoup
parlé d' éviter on a beaucoup parlé de
la présence
d'à présence des dignitaires aujourd'hui
anita la nouvelle ministre de la défense
qui sera là un peu plus tard femmes
première femme depuis kim kembo à
travers tout ça les forces ont quand
même été passablement secoué au cours
des dernières années par toute la
question des inconduites quel point est
ce que ça vient secouer le moral des
troupes d'après vous c'est
certain que en ce moment je pense qu'une
question de regagner la confiance en
fait de l'apport d'éléments des forces
armées canadien lorsqu'on voit les
tailles des dirigeants d' un peu tombés
au combat
ça déstabilise beaucoup en fait les
filles de se sentir en sécurité au sein
même de son organisation
donc je pense qu'en ce moment d'avoir
des personnes je dirais de tête fort
dont le vieux avec madame anna qui a pas
hésité à prendre des actions
immédiatement après que l'économie donc
je pense que c'est ce qu'on a besoin de
faire de prendre des actions rapides
pour justement que les éléments des
forces armées canadiennes puissent avoir
confiance en leur système en europe et
en ré mineur
va coûter le au canada on va bientôt
[Musique]
unitaire qui sont
le monument commémoratif de guerre après
le salut bissau royale et au canada il
ya eu le passage des trois avions de
chasse cf 18 qui sont dépêchés de
l'escadre de bach d'huile
participent à la cérémonie chaque année
vous les voyez placé devant les
l'endroit où ils iront déposer tout à
l'heure la gerbe de fleurs en mémoire
soldats canadiens qui sont tombés au
combat un gouverneur général sera la
première elle ira déposer
sa gerbe au nom de tous les canadiens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
foule considérable sur la place de la
confédération nettement plus importantes
que les dernières alors qu'on avait
demandé au public de ne pas se présenter
mesdames et messieurs au canada avec les
membres de la musique centrale des
forces armées canadiennes et du choeur
des enfants de 3
[Musique]
tu
non
pour
pour cent
[Musique]
bbb
à
enfin
et
[Musique]
enfin
le championnat est long
et cher la bride aux liseuses kindle
attaque michael dawson et rooney oui oui
mais
ils ne vivront pas comme nous qui leur
avons servi qu
ils ne connaîtront jamais le courage ni
le poids des années
quand viendra l'heure du crépuscule et
sandro nous nous souviendrons d'heure
je m'appelle nous allons encore nous
sommes sûr pas accaparer los
angeles ou sheep et kanchi ce l'est pas
noir frappé des gens
y étaient joue qu'on nous on y serez
safran ses réseaux nous promettons que
même si est impasse du porteur de flamme
et puis je vais rouler à watou jours /
ap 12 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
dans le respect des croyances et des
consciences individuelles
je vous invite à prendre le moment de
recueillement
aujourd'hui en présence d'anne aux
anciens combattants nous nous rappelons
ces hommes et ces femmes se sont battus
avec en art et courage afin que nous
puissions vivre aujourd'hui dans un pays
où les valeurs de liberté de fierté et
de courage résonne avec puissance
notre histoire pour apprendre le trim
nationale est une épopée de brillants
exploits qui forcent notre admiration et
qui nous pousse aujourd'hui à nous
dépasser et à être meilleur
en effet nous sommes ici rassemblés avec
le coeur rempli de gratitude et de
fierté pour nos militaires canadiens
d'hier à aujourd'hui qui ont fait le
sacrifice ultime
ainsi que pour nos blessés qui pend
encore dans leur corps et dans leur âme
des blessures de nos combats
jamais
jamais nous ne ferons le devoir de se
souvenir car il est le lieu où nous
puisons fausses et résilience
nous sommes fiers
nous sommes très fiers de faire partie
de cette histoire est d'avoir mené le
combat
sous le drapeau canadien
weprin
nous prions pour les dirigeants de tous
les niveaux et de façon toute
particulière pour sa majesté la reine la
gouverneure générale le premier ministre
le ministre de la défense ou la ministre
la défense et le chef d'état major de la
défense
réparer nous à faire face à tout ce qui
pourrait opposer
l'inclusion ou l'intégrité que ce soit
dans nos coeurs ou dans les gestes des
autres
afin que nous puissions être plus fort
dans nos valeurs partagées et le service
rendu au canada
la guerre déchire
la guerre
des membres ce qui est un tout afin de
se souvenir c'est de rapatrier ceux qui
ont été arrachés au tissu national c'est
notre devoir de nous rappeler de nous
remémorer
car nous vivons comme ceux qui ont
grandi d'un la paix la paix qui est un
cadeau de nos ancêtres
c'est ainsi que nous pouvons rendre
hommage à laure legs et nous participons
ici alors travail noble
la pandémie mondiale continuent de faire
obstacle à notre essor chacun à une
nouvelle appréciation de la collectivité
de la communauté des êtres chers
ce que nous n'avons pas pu voir en
personne
et pourtant nous savons qu'il reste
encore beaucoup à faire chacun et
chacune entre nous on a à s'occuper à
s'occuper d'autrui à promouvoir le bien
commun qui nous lie les uns aux autres
fut-ce la commémoration aujourd'hui nous
inspirer à travailler ensemble pour un
meilleur avenir
amen
mesdames et messieurs le cortège royal
déposera maintenant les couronnes
canada correction 6
mai
la gouverneure générale du canada son
excellence la très honorable mairie mais
si manu
[Musique]
il le temps
les nageurs us madden madame josée
simard
ma mère nationales de la croix d'argent
madame josée simard
[Musique]
la plus intime de garden of canada
le gouvernement du canada notre le
ministre le très honorable justin
trudeau
[Musique]
voilà on vient d'entendre on vient de
voir la cérémonie vous avez remarqué
qu'il y avait eu un retard considérable
une semaine
[Musique]
exactement ce qu'ils ont dit
s'entendre
l'organisation et qu'on aura plus
d'explications sur ce qui s'est passé
après la cérémonie entre temps je vais
rejoindre laurence martin qui était sur
place qui est au monument commémoratif
de guerre laurence vous avez eu
l'occasion vous entretenir avec la
nouvelle ministre de la défense a need
and
we qui participent à ces cérémonies du
11 novembre pour la première fois
justement en tant que ministre de la
défense qui est seulement la deuxième
femme dans l'histoire canadienne à avoir
été nommé à la tête de la défense il
n'avait duré que quelques mois
madame qui avaient mon poste avec un
ministère et surtout une illusion et
confirmé qu'ils ont connue quand même
une année difficile parce que tous ces
scandales à des contacts sexuels
rader de l'armée et aussi quand même le
retrait des troupes de l'otan de
l'afghanistan quand on sait tous les
canadiens qui sont allés justement là
bas pour combattre c'est un jour du
souvenir qui est particulièrement
éprouvant pour certains certains qui se
demandent à quoi est-ce que ça a servi
finalement toute cette mission et c'est
une question que j'ai posée à madame
annales qu'est-ce qui est resté de cette
mission voici sa réponse
c'est le service qui c'est important
chaque jour de nos forces armées
canadiens ici au canada en afghanistan
et partout dans le monde et aussi de
protéger les vies de les populations
domestique là et aussi de sauver notre
pays et notre mission
j'ai aussi demandé daniel à manama nancy
elle avait hésité avant d'accepter ce
poste parce que comme on l'a dit
beaucoup de défis on sait qu'à ottawa
son nom circule est là depuis plusieurs
semaines sur la colline parlementaire
plusieurs la voyait à ce poste alors je
vais demander comme support audio vous
approchez comment est-ce que ça c'est
fait exactement
je n'hésite pas quand il m'a demandé
d'avoir d'assumer cette position j'ai dû
j'ai dit oui bien sûr je vais je vais
servir
n'importe classe avec
humilité j'ai mon propre truc du lest
avant qu'yves ou non avant oui j'ai
écrit une petite liste dans ma journal
j'ai discuté cette liste avec mon équipe
le premier jour après la cérémonie
qu'est-ce qui avait son moteur to do
list de créer une culture dans les
forces armées canadien pour les femmes
pour tout le monde à voir les
protections
d'ailleurs un daniel l'une des premières
choses que madame annan a annoncé la
semaine dernière c'est que les plaintes
d'agression sexuelle dans l'armée seront
traités au civil il faut par une cour
martiale ce qui avait une demande depuis
plusieurs années envers le gouvernement
entre dos voilà madame kv7 oudoul et si
on me le dit le salissent de choses elle
voulait avant même d'être nommé et donc
qui a déjà commencé à agir la semaine
dernière
seulement
je viens que nos deux invités
elle est de ces leurres rémi landry
laurence il faisait allusion enitan et
là tout un contrat de bot elle est là la
du boulot et doit donner un coup de
barre à l'organisation militaire qui a
été secoué par une série de scandales
d'inconduite rémy à quel point comment
vous voyez le travail qu'il a de
vareilles
jeu dans un premier temps je pense qu'il
faut réaliser que il ya des jeux des
mesures qui ont été mis en place
entre août avec madame à rebours entre
autres avec la lieutenant général je
crois qu à rien qu'ils sont en train de
faire le tour des bases rencontrer des
gens pour être en mesure peut-être une
meilleure compréhension et puis surtout
de d'évaluer ce qui a été fait depuis
2015 avec l'opération en or donc je
crois que ce qu'elles vont être en
mesure de faire c'est de faire comme
elodie de donner un coup de barre et
puis de s'assurer qu'on s'engage sur un
chemin qui vont éventuellement mettre
fin
à ces comportements inappropriés puis
comme elle le gouvernement le mentionner
dorénavant tout ce qui est allégations
d'inconduite sexuelle sera
remis
cour civile donc en espérant que les
personnes qui auront subi des
conséquences de ces agressions l'eau en
droit à une justice peut-être plus
approprié elle est née c'est là on a
l'impression qu'elle a pas un qui
répondent beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre
tous les gens les yeux sont tournés sur
elle madame anna d'erollisi on veut que
ça bouge et on a l'impression aussi
qu'il faut que ça bouge parce que ça
secouer un peu le moral des troupes sen
au sein des forces
mais s'applique lorsque le premier
rapport a été déposé où il y avait des
recommandations assez clair quitte à
demander des forces armées canadiennes
mais on se rend compte au final que les
choses dans les faits n'avaient pas été
nécessairement à cliquer donc
aujourd'hui on prenne le temps a qu'une
un deuxième rapport justement de prendre
action là je pense que c'est ça on
arrive à 23h59 et on doit absolument
agir on veut que les gens qui servent au
sein des forces armées canadiennes
francky quand même une forme de
discipline de loyauté et de surtout de
sécurité face à leurs services je pense
qu'il était grand temps parce qu'on
aurait entendu des histoires je pense
d'horreur qu'on pourrait qu'elle fit sur
des justement des dix plaintes qui ont
été déposées puis le présent et qui ont
été montés vécu ensuite chez ces
questions qui ont déposé les plein
d'autres et 1b main de fer l'action qui
était nécessaire depuis longtemps
sks que ça envoie un signal est ce qu on
a senti humilié signal de la nomination
madame anne
je crois qu'il était peut-être temps je
r2 de mettre de nouveau une femme comme
minustah défense
pour plusieurs raisons de morin a le
passé qui semble
assez évident que c'est une femme
d'action qui était en mesure de montrer
son efficience et son efficacité dans
son ancien ministère mais en même temps
aussi de montrer qu'on est sur une route
non pas de changement mais une route ou
éventuellement c'est un acquis des
femmes sont à parts égales au sein des
forces armées canadiennes et puis comme
tel lovett traités dans le respect et
puis avec tous les égards jr qui leur
sont dues donc je crois que ces deux
qualificatifs le font en sorte que cela
envoie un message est clair du rôle que
les femmes
jouent et puis vont continuer de jouer
au sein des forces et puis moi je m'en
cache pas je dis oh j'ai servi sous le
commandement d'une femme et je dois
avouer que l'expérience loin d'avoir été
négative au contraire ils ont leur rôle
au sein des forces armées canadiennes et
puis on le vit aussi en afghanistan le
fait d'avoir des femmes au sein de nos
troupes nous permet d'être en mesure
d'en faire plus lorsqu'on a dans les
missions de paix ou d'émissions ce qu'on
doit éventuellement travailler avec la
communauté civile des pays à l'intérieur
duquel on opère ned évoquer
l'afghanistan
lnc l'heure on a vu cet été les images
de kaboul qui retombait aux mains des
talibans après que les derniers
militaires alors que les lits militaire
coalition se préparaient à partir qu'est
ce que ça vient qu'est ce que ça vient
faire c'est un quelques jambes et pas
que ça sur la communauté de vie terrain
j'ai en fait je veux jeu sur la
communauté de vie dira quand on regarde
tout le travail qui a été fait là bas
ce qui est un regret est ce qu'il ya une
déception je pense qu'on va l'écouter
d'abord la bénédiction je vais je vais
revenir à vue puis après on my world je
suis ici aujourd'hui
autant de ce mois nous croient de
l'histoire et le coup remplie de
souvenirs récents et moi
ait un jury des prix bas mike rann
faveur ninety phising pour mes 15 ans
qui est servi notre pays pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale madame marine
le
frère de mon grand-oncle a également
servi sous les drapeaux et à tout jamais
porter les cicatrices de services en
velin en 1945 sur heures l'as wihr
hospital y vivent mais rempli de ces
fragments d'os luc allait demeurer avec
lui pour le reste de sa vie je suis avec
vous aujourd'hui à penser au cénotaphe
de canard à ce hall mémorial ici à
ottawa construit par ceux qui ont servi
en afghanistan afin d'honorer la mémoire
de ceux qui ont perdu la vie là-bas du
personnel militaires et des civils
également
et je réfléchis à l'image de genève et
terrain qui rendent hommage au cénotaphe
de canard à honorer leurs frères et leur
soeur tomber qui ont consenti le
sacrifice ultime pour chacun d'entre
nous
partout au canada je suis là debout
devant voix réfléchir à ces histoires et
aux innombrables autres qu'elles
représentent des symboles de notre
engagement indéfectible au nom de la
liberté
face à la tyrannie
des anciens combattants jours et moi je
we stand nous sommes là ensemble dès
aujourd'hui avec une gratte de profondes
pour le sacrifice ultime
les plus courageux d'entre nous visant à
défendre les valeurs de la liberté
partout où ces valeurs ont été menacés
nous sommes là ensemble avec dycker qui
déborde en reconnaissant que ce
sacrifice sacré va au delà de nouveaux
terrains jusqu à leur famille à leurs
êtres chers à leur mère et leur père
alors marie à leur épouse et partenaire
de vie à leurs enfants et aussi à leur
fratrie nous sommes ensemble ici dans
leurs connaissances tout table de tous
ceux qui vont revenir au canada avec le
clin d'oeil mais avec des blessures
profondes néanmoins nous sommes là
pour rendre hommage à nos forces
canadiennes et du passé du présent
aujourd'hui à tous les jours pour ceux
qui ont servi en temps de guerre et ceux
qui ont été 2009 sur les lignes de front
et c'est chez nous et qui sont venus en
aide aux communautés qui ont vécu des
crises et des besoins urgents que ce
soit une pandémie des incendies ou des
inondations
nous sommes là aujourd'hui en sachant
que nous pouvons jouir la bénédiction de
notre pays nordiques libre et fort en
grande partie grâce à chacun chacun
d'entre vous
nous forces armées canadiennes
honoré nous sommes et c'est encore
ensemble pour déclarer haut et fort nous
sommes à vos côtés
et en ce moment aujourd'hui nous pouvons
réfléchir
ben ball causés ces derniers mots de sa
dernière bénédiction le 11 novembre de
mes voeux
de faire du canada un pays où de
nouveaux terrains et surtout digne de
leurs sacrifices leur dévouement pays
définis par le respect par l'harmonie
par l'inclusion par la responsabilité et
la gentillesse envers tous et toutes
que dieu bénisse nos vétérans que dieu
bénisse nous trop peu et que dieu
bénisse tous ceux et celles qui se
tiennent aux efforts sous les drapeaux
les champions de la paix les champions
de la sécurité de la tranquillité que
dieu bénisse le canada
amen
[Musique]
avec le choeur des enfants d'autres
et
[Musique]
la gouverneure générale du canada son
excellence la très honorable mais remind
on sera maintenant le salut vis moyal
[Musique]
hu
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les habitudes des cérémonies auront
remarqué qu' il ya des éléments qui sont
pas dans l'ordre habituel c'est
clairement lié aux retards d'une dizaine
de minutes que l'on a accusé en début de
cérémonie le saluer son voyage ou venez
voir normalement il aurait dû avoir lieu
l arrivée de mary sa et mène sur le site
on devrait en savoir plus en courant de
la journée sur les raisons qui
pourraient expliquer ce retard
cérémonie est essentiellement terminée
ceci dit à ce stade si les dignitaires
qui sont sur place mais ne vous le voyez
l'avant les visites et va les rencontrer
des vétérans hal est allé voir les gens
qui sont sur place messieurs trudeau la
ministre de la défense devrait faire de
même
elle est le seul à rémi landry que j'ai
abruptement interrompu un peu plus tôt
toutes mes excuses je vous reviens
madame le salaire on parlait de
l'afghanistan on parlait des images que
l'on a vu cet été la chute de kaboul aux
mains des talibans est-ce que ça vienne
a été un peu une partie du travail qui a
été fait par les militaires canadiens là
bas
en fait c'est certain que ça a mis une
grande réflexion parce que quelque part
ce qu'on ait terminé la mission en
afghanistan
la réalité sur le terrain et que ce pays
l'heure n'était pas à l'aise avec
conflit n'était pas terminé et donc on a
quitté un peu dans un moment inachevé on
dirait de l'addition donc c'est un peu
le sentiment je pense qu'ils habitent
beaucoup de vétérans beaucoup militaires
encore puis lorsqu'on voit des talibans
à prendre du terrain où on a combattu où
on a gagné en fait pour sécuriser des
portions de ce pays le pour la
population c'est certain qu'on vit des
moments de colère de frustration
d'amertume mais je pense qu'il faut pas
oublier aussi que lorsqu'on était en
afghanistan la dizaine d'années qu'on
était là et on a affaire grand moment de
répit à la population ou les jeunes
femmes on peut retourner sur les bancs
d'école lorsqu'on a vu justement le
rapatriement de certains d'abyan au mois
d'août que c'est des jeunes femmes qui
avaient graduée soit de l'université
donc on doit se rappeler qu'on a connu
des avancées de connu des succès je
pense qu'il faut aussi pour la mémoire
des disparus
la mémoire des personnes qui ont perdu
la vie au combat on doit se rappeler
pour nos prophètes cette mission là en
vain parce que c'est ce que je pense
déshonoré leur mémoire donc je pense
qu'il faut vraiment se rappeler que
malgré que ça peut amener des sentiments
que sont l'eau peut être plus difficile
faut se rappeler des bons coups qu'on a
confiées en a bien un instant rémi
landry est ce qu'il ya des gens au sein
des forces qui ont à difficulté à faire
la part des choses se passent bien on a
quand même fait un travail qui compte
quand tu y vois ces images là comme on
les a vues cet été je suis d'accord avec
ce qui vient d'être dit je dis oui il ya
eu des belles choses qui ont été faites
naturellement ce qui est inquiétant pour
plusieurs
des vétérans fait deux pas
nécessairement en savoir l'état des
interprètes afghans avec lesquels ils
ont travaillé je pense que c'est ça qui
fait le plus mal c'est sexy gens là ont
mis leur vie à notre disposition à la
disposition des militaires et qui
aujourd'hui ont le sentiment qu'on n'a
pas tout fait pour garantir leur
sécurité
l'autre chose aussi qui est qui et qui
est désolant c'est on ne générer vent
d'espoir à cette population là on a eu
de plus en plus de femmes qui
éventuellement qui pouvait circuler
librement et puis là ce qui est
inquiétant c'est de voir que peut-être
l'espoir les grands de ce point qu'on le
sommet baky éventuellement les été
enlevés espérons je veux dire que les
gouvernements de la communauté
internationale seront en mesure
éventuellement de de pouvoir
permettre un certain retour à une
certaine normalité
mais pour l'instant moi c'est ça qui
m'inquiète et puis il faut
définitivement pas oublier les gens qui
ont donné leur vie et puis ceux qui en
souffrent encore aujourd'hui le
confie la effectivement
monsieur landry madame nécessaire si
vous permettez on va aller faire un show
ottawa parce que ma collègue laurence
portait sur place et
elle a même plus d'informations sur ce
qui explique le retard qui était
imposante cérémonie ce matin
oui exactement moi j'ai une part les
quelques personnes dans l'entourage du
premier ministre tout doux et ce qu'on
nous dit c'est que la raison pour
laquelle c'était à refaire en fait plus
une question de sécurité il y aurait
d'après ce qu'on comprend peut-être un
colis suspect lui qui aurait été repéré
par la police d'ottawa et dont on aurait
demandé au premier ministre de retarder
son arrivée on n'en sait pas plus pour
l'instant daniel on nous dit qu'un
inconnu qui doit être émis dans les
prochaines minutes maintenant moi j'ai
pu rencontrer aussi parce qu'on vous
aide il à la foulée d'euros il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont sur place pour
cette cérémonie donc des gens donc qui
sont venus assister à cette cérémonie du
jour du souvenir j'aurais demandé
comment est ce qu'il vivait ça surtout
après ce qui s'est passé en afghanistan
dans les derniers mois ce que c'était un
jour de souvenir peut-être plus
difficile est ce qu'ils avaient
l'impression que les canadiens avaient
dans certains cas peut-être servi pour
rien voici quelques témoignages pour
leurs griffes
des vies ont été perdues et puis on n'a
pas réussi à avoir le but alors oui
c'est
surtout pour tous les parents qui ont
perdu des
les gars ont alors fait c'est symbolique
très difficile pour moi le 11 novembre
c'est la rose avant peu importe qu'est
ce qui est à ski
[Musique]
week
on voyait des impressions daniel prêts
très différente de l'importance de cette
mission et de ce jour souvenir puis
jusqu'aux dents en terminant on va
tenter justement d'avoir plus de détails
par rapport à tout ce qui s'est passé
donc c'est un enjeu de sécurité les
retards d'une dizaine de minutes le
début de la cérémonie
et
nous aurons de nouveau à l'historien
laurent adjoint philip thivierge se dire
j'aurais beaucoup vu madame même semaine
depuis le début à quel point est-ce que
chez les premières nations cette
nomination là parce qu'elle est devenue
la commandante des forces armées
essentiellement à accepter un poste de
gouverneur général qu'est ce que ça a eu
comme mes courses chez les premières
nations les
réparations parce que les opinions
divergent certainement
est évidemment certains critiques face à
la position de toute façon qu'elle
occupe comme tel mais évidemment on est
très friand de symboles français
je crois que ce symbole a été accueillie
ouvertement comme m
l'idée qui a une place de plus en plus
importante aux plus hautes sphères de
l'état canadien
la place des autochtones aussi madame
thurman et inuit
certainement
chez les quads motos autochtones au
canada on a parlé de l'importance de
georges hugnet repoussa là et comment il
est souligné le jour du souvenir chez
les populations autochtones
écoutez les souni de nombreuses manières
parce que la perception des vides la
participation des autochtones à travers
l'ensemble du canada est tellement
diverse et les réactions pour la
roulement ou aux différents conflits
mondiaux et est tellement multiples on
pourrait en parler des heures légumes
par exemple je veux parler de chez moi
un wind acquis et en ce moment
c'est comme une cérémonie comme à tous
les commissaires tous les uns et et nous
cherchons à communiquer à entrer en
contact avec d'autres à des militaires
par exemple donc le royal 22e régiment à
valcartier et bien toutes les années
avec une unité il ya une parade
il ya des discours il ya des députés
fédéraux provinciaux et qui sont
présentes c'est qu'on est tout seul
cette communion là ça nous permet de se
rappeler encore par les doubles il
essayer de contrer l'oubli même et où
l'abus oublier le souvenir à jamais le
souvenir jamais quitté les esprits ont
le jeu serait affirmé et bien
aujourd'hui c'est une grande opportunité
cette journée si pour nous et je vais
pas lui personnellement c'est aussi une
journée au pas de reconnaissance et un
peu mais ceux ci une journée pour se
réapproprier une partie de notre
identité
moi je le vois de cette manière de voir
les actions passées de nos vétérans
comme les vétérans de ma nation qui sont
allés aux dieux qu'on passe aux deux
conflits mondiaux la compréhension de la
réaction au lieu de juste glorifier leur
action comme tel la compréhension de ces
actions là nous permet aussi
d'obtenir une plus grande capacité à
construire notre identité et pour moi je
pense que c'est essentiel de le
valoriser cette manière et on y arrive
de plus en plus par différents moyens
donc ça justifie d'autant plus la
légitimité de souligner jour du souvenir
chez moune allait commander et dans
toute la démarche entamée par le
gouvernement fédéral
de réconciliation comment est-ce que le
jour du souvenir la participation des
peuples autochtones ou confirmer comment
est-ce que ça s'inscrive deux prévenus
écoutez son part de l'idée de la
reconnaissance
la laddh il est indéniable et les
recherches récentes nous demande de plus
en plus que la participation des
autochtones aux deux conflits mondiaux
et au prorata de sa population aux
différentes époques et est la plus
grande la plus importante participation
en pourcentage pour une quelconque
minorité au au canada on parle de 35 à
40% de non retour de l'autre c'est
énorme quelques centaines de morts
quelques milliers ou par les quatre
mille 4000 l'engager première et
deuxième guerre mondiale mais je vous
réfère à des régions des recherches
récentes d'un certain ian kelly
tellement qui a fait de manière
volontaire des recherches pendant des
années qui nous a mis sur la piste que
ça c'est les gens déclaré non parle de
probablement près de 15000 autochtone et
je parle de sica jeudi attaquant du père
premières nations métis inuits qui c'est
qui qui se sentent engagés parce que des
milliers ne se sont jamais déclaré
aujourd'hui on essaie de promouvoir ce
souvenir là je crois moi je les dis
tantôt je crois que ça devait marche le
bien qu'on ne veut pas glorifier le
contexte militaire pas si on veut s'en
servir aussi pour rappeler
que l'on a une place en tant qu'acteur
et que le chemin pour y est le chemin
était difficile de voir un important
devoir de mémoire de ce côté là jean
philippe meyer merci infiniment d'avoir
été des nôtres dans cadre de cette
émission spéciale l'es6
si loin et je joins à camille carpentier
qui elle est à la croix du sacrifice à
québec où on a souligné jour du souvenir
que mais je crois que monsieur legault
ne s'est pas adressé à la foule qui
tenait ce matin
non mais il vient tout juste de prendre
la parole et s'est adressé aux médias il
ya quelques instants il n'ya pas
décemment prix de questions mais ça
s'est passé de l'autre côté donc tout
juste à côté de l'assemblée nationale la
cérémonie a pris fin ici quelques
minutes déjà mais vous voyez il ya
encore des gens qui prennent le temps de
venir se recueillir devant le cénotaphe
devant la croix du sacrifice il y avait
quelques centaines de personnes je vous
dirai qu'ils ont assisté à cette
cérémonie donc c'était une foule assez
substantiel je vous dirais malgré les
mesures sanitaires qui empêchait qu'on a
un nombre illimité cette année d'inviter
officielle donc tous à commencer par une
parade de la 5e brigade mécanisé du
canada qui donc qui est sorti de la
citadelle on est tout juste à côté de la
citadelle et des plaines d'abraham ici à
québec il est accompagné de membres de
la marine canadienne de membres du
service de police de la ville de québec
également et donc évidemment un peu
avant 11h moment de recueillement moment
de silence et puis sur le coup de 11h
coup de canon présence également survols
d'hélicoptères l'acquis qui sont passés
ici au dessus du lieu où on se trouve
ensuite a évidemment plusieurs
dignitaires ont déposé des gerbes de
fleurs donc des couronnes de fleurs
devant le cénotaphe évidemment leur
premier ministre françois legault le
nouveau maire le maire désigné de québec
également bruno marchand qui étaient
présents des chefs d opposition
officielle donc à l'assemblée nationale
et puis jean yves duclos le nouveau
ministre fédérale de la santé qui
étaient là pour représenter le
gouvernement et canadien donc évidemment
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un moment de grande
émotion pour les vétérans il ya
plusieurs vétérans ici à québec avec la
présence de la base militaire de
valcartier dont j'ai parlé à des
vétérans à des membres des forces armées
canadiennes encore en poste aujourd'hui
je leur ai demandé qu'est ce que ça
signifiait le jour du souvenir pour eux
voici quelques réponses
mais cette journée qui est quand même
rempli d'émotions ce que l'on veut
portillon on a perdu des gens au combat
puis on a que j'ai quand même 32 ans
service donc si gignac est relativement
difficile
scellait la perte de nos confrères que
ce soit les vies humaines nous et de
troubles post traumatiques ces choses
bien qui m'a touché beaucoup beaucoup je
vais vous dire de suite s'il s'appelle
simon long terme
simon 6 mois qui a donné son corps des
rebelles puis quand j'ai décidé que je
l'aï vu atterrir ça m'a touché
donc on sent l'importance de se souvenir
encore aujourd'hui moment d'émotion
d'autant plus que je me rappelle l'année
dernière ça a été impossible de tenir
une cérémonie du jour du souvenir alors
pour pour les vétérans là c'était
c'était bien de souligner les finalement
cette journée d'aujourd'hui oui
effectivement moment d'émotion toujours
merci à camilla québec s'éloigne
également à la base militaire de
bagotville au saguenay lac saint jean
des discours ont été prononcés deux
minutes de silence a également été
observée et des gerbes de fleurs ont été
déposées une pensée entre autres pour un
membre de la base de caporal dany
olivier fortin qui a perdu la vie en
afghanistan 2009 la base construite en
1942 durant la seconde guerre mondiale
emploie aujourd'hui 1700 employés
militaires et civils et des
commémorations ont également eu lieu à
montréal où des centaines de personnes
ont d'abord assisté à une messe ce matin
à la cathédrale marie reine du monde une
cérémonie commémorative s'est ensuite
tenue à la place du canada en présence
de la mairesse et lui valérie plante qui
est venu déposer une couronne de fleurs
l'arrivée de lagarde a aussi été précédé
par 21 coups de canon et pour clore les
commémorations un défilé se mettra
bientôt en branle dans les rues du
centre ville de la métropole
et je retrouve mes deux collaborateurs
pour cette émission spéciale dernier
tour de table hélène je commence avec
vous que ce qu'on retient de cette
journée du 11 novembre de ce jour du
second lui
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin
de se rappeler surtout de grands efforts
de réconciliation devait et envers les
peuples autochtones mais je pense aussi
qu'il faut se rappeler que ils font sens
mais canadienne où nos vétérans c'est
une diversité c'est un c du
multiculturalisme je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on doit se rappeler
pour pouvoir gagner confiance dans le
fond envers notre système défendant me
canadienne je pense que c'est pour le
bénéfice en fuite de tous ceux et celles
qui sont ou qui ont servi à voir une
reconnaissance envers toutes ces
individus là c'est important de
commémorer ensuite de se dire que ce
n'est pas seulement le 11 novembre qu'on
doit commémorer mais en fait tous les
jours dany rémi landry il ya évidemment
des besoins commémorer il ya aussi le
besoin de s'assurer qu'on répond des
filles des futurs vétérans il changer
d'ici là en espagne effectivement on
parle beaucoup des familles mais il faut
aussi peut-être parler des enfants parce
que de plus en plus je veux dire les
mots nos militaires canadiens qui sont
décédés en afghanistan ces projets
des jeunes hommes aux jeunes femmes
célibataires mais y en a plusieurs que
c'était d'aider des parents de plusieurs
enfants donc oui c'est excellent de se
rappeler de mettre les maires en
évidence mais il faut il faut il faut
définitivement avoir une pensée pour
tous ces jeunes enfants là qui ont perdu
leurs parents un de la un de leurs
parents et puis éventuellement de
réaliser une fois pour toutes que les
militaires canadiens sont l'eau au
service et en plus une notion de
sacrifice que ces gens le font au
quotidien pour être en mesure de garder
le canada comme il est actuellement que
peut-être un terrain de salaire et un
colonel à la retraite rémi landry merci
infiniment d'avoir bien voulu être des
nôtres nous tout au long de cette
émission c'est était très éclairant
merci à vous deux c'est là dessus que se
termine cette émission spéciale jour du
souvenir merci à vous tous à la maison
d'avoir été là il était gérant du midi
suis dans un instant il nous restait sur
des images des moments les plus
marquants de ces cérémonies c'est daniel
thibault à montréal à très bientôt
[Musique]
avant
au
chanteur
[Musique]
vous
un système juridique
[Musique]